before we begin since this is a bbc
owned property i feel the need to point
out that the news arm of the bbc has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pin comment below various
videos from both myself and other
youtubers covering this issue and while
i understand that the doctor who
creative team is not responsible for
this i will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
if you really want to understand
somebody
take a look at the company they keep
[Music]
well hello there folks i am continuing
to um do some well redo some uh rankings
for doctor who that i've done in the
past and one of the more highly viewed
ones that i did a little while ago was
the ranking of all the modern day
companions and it's time i revisit that
however in the interest of having this
be more than just slotting in i think it
ends up being about four companions who
weren't included in my original list i
am also going to change my criteria so
when i did it before in that previous
list
my criteria was that i counted as a
companion
anyone who appeared in more than one
story and reminder i count two parters
that has only one story appeared in more
than one story and actually traveled in
the tardis not just saw it not just
entered it actually traveled in it now i
did actually end up missing um
vincent who technically met my criteria
and i didn't realize that but that was
the basis for that original list now
that criteria actually caused me some
headaches at the time because even
though like i said i missed vincent it
did let in a bunch of people who i would
rather not have talked about like
angionardi adam mitchell jackie tyler
characters who it kind of felt odd to
include his companions but they met the
criteria i set out so i did this time
i'm changing the criteria this time i'm
going to count as a companion anyone
who's actor was named in the opening
title credits accepting of course
someone who's playing the doctor and
also actually the master because john
simm was listed in the opening credits
for the end of time so discounting them
because yeah those aren't companions
anyone who had their name listed that is
going to bring them on board so that
actually means this list is only
slightly shorter than the previous one i
think only by like one or two people
because the previous list while it
brought in some folks like adam mitchell
angie and already like i mentioned it
also left out all of the one-off
companions from the specials this
criteria that i'm you that i'm using now
ditches some of the random folks who
slipped in before but does bring in all
the one-timers so this is actually a
fairly different list from the ground up
although a lot of the same people
obviously still appear so that's the
criteria i'm using this time oh and i
should probably also you know copped to
the fact that um part of the reason i
alter my criteria is that my old
criteria captain mickey smith my new
criteria allows me to discard him and i
really don't want to talk about no clark
uh or the character he portrays so like
that's in the mix but i still think it
was worth it to change the criteria
anyways but
before i get started there's 23 of these
i don't actually dislike
any of them
i like all of these it's just a matter
of who i like best so even the one at
the very bottom number 23 where we're
gonna start
i'm okay with them i don't have a
problem with them they're not bad
but i still have to do this in some kind
of order so
here we go
starting with number 23
lady christina de souza
from
the dead planet or is it planet of the
dead i can't remember i always get it
mixed up in any case
she is a
nobility she is an adventurer she just
likes the thrill she's very take command
she's got great chemistry with tenant
which she kind of needs so why do i have
her all the way down here well
because she's kind of too perfect
and that's actually kind of by design
the whole intent with her narratively
was to create a companion like boy they
would have been great together but we're
not doing that so it kind of exists as a
that would have been neat but it never
was sort of thing which i mean i think
that's kind of an interesting thing to
do on purpose but part of the thing is
as a result there isn't actually much
depth to their dynamic they just click
well together
and that's kind of it
oddly while their chemistry is one of
the better aspects of a not such a great
special
i am left thinking you know
i get that they work decently together
i don't feel like i actually need to
ever see them on another adventure
though because
i'm left feeling what i saw here is just
what the dynamic would almost always be
it didn't feel like it had room for
change or for growth which again by
design it didn't need it
but it did just kind of leave me going
that's
good chemistry but that's a real simple
dynamic and just based on the criteria
of i wouldn't really be that interested
in seeing them together again
that's why she's at the bottom
number 22
astrid peth
so i feel a little bad putting astrid
way down here but again it's kind of the
obviousness of it she does seem in many
ways crafted to just be almost kind of
an ideal companion for tenant you know
someone who is excited wants adventure
is is ready to go out and explore the
stars and who he has a decent connection
with just seems like a fundamentally
good person
in this case it's constructed for
tragedy rather than kind of a oh that's
a shame they never got together thing
the way it is with christina and as a
result i feel like astrid has just a
little bit more depth and honestly i
kind of feel like
um rtd is just better at kind of
needling the feels with a character like
astrid and i like that astrid you know
made that choice to sacrifice herself to
save well the doctor and by extension
basically everybody else that
takes a lot to do
and i think it boosts her up just a
little over christina even though in
terms of my overall feel on them they're
actually quite
similar in terms of my assessment even
though the characters are fairly
different
number 21
captain archival lethbridge stewart from
twice upon a time
mark gadis playing uh a relation i think
it's grandfather
it's either grandfather father i'd like
i did the math at one point to figure
out which it was and i can't remember
now but um of
the brigadier brigadier lethbridge
stewart and
he's actually a really nice presence the
reason he's this far down just largely
has to do with the fact that he doesn't
do much i mean honestly the first doctor
functions more like a companion to the
12th doctor than this character
functions as a companion to either of
them that said he brings a good sense of
stoicism he has that
sense of duty that you that just makes
sense for somebody who is in the
trenches in world war one probably
recognizes that this entire situation is
messed up but still feels an obligation
to perform duty he brings that across in
a way that isn't
just a
cliche just oh stiff up a lip okay like
there's some of that there but it's
clearly
a facade it's hiding a lot of
fear and pain and doubt and he portrays
that very well
but again the reason he's down here is
not because the characterization is bad
but just because the character doesn't
do much he's mostly just a vehicle to
get us to the christmas armistice which
he's effective at that but there isn't
much more to him as far as use in the
story
next up number 20 stepping away from uh
one-off companions from specials we have
ryan sinclair
ryan was a character who honestly
it was actually kind of hard for me to
assess ryan and graham as separate
entities because a lot of their stuff
was based off playing off each other and
working together but when i tried to
assess them separately ryan
kind of had the least going on as a
character
i mean we could go on about the uh
depiction of his dyspraxia how well that
was handled how often the show seemed to
forget that he had it or brought it up
at odd moments where it actually didn't
impact anything and ryan is a pleasant
enough guy to have a round
he just doesn't seem to bring much
with him like i said the main thing he
seemed to bring was an extra dynamic for
graham to have but as a character unto
himself
he often just feels like he's along for
the ride now he's not distracting i
don't feel that he drags things down
with his presence but he also doesn't
contribute a great deal so why is he
above some of the others honestly just
by virtue of the fact that he was a
regular companion and if he can stick
around for two full series plus a
special in there and i'm not going uh
you really are starting to drag things
down well then then clearly he at least
works over a long period of time and
that's worth a little bit more than the
one-offs that i listed before
number 19 this will probably be my most
controversial placement
that this person wasn't at the bottom
well no it won't be but i suspect some
people are going to be like what uh mad
jar well now look
i know it's become very in fashion to
hate the hell
out of the doctor the widow and the
wardrobe
i kind of like it like it's cheesy
and it's kind of dumb
but i like it
and most of what i like about it is
admittedly match i like that motherly
yet yet somewhat commanding presence
that she has like it's it's maternal but
like firm-handed maternal and she has
just
just for me for my taste just the right
level of quirkiness to her that easily
can and often times uh does get
overplayed when you deliberately make a
quirky character for me it was just the
right amount of quirky and you can see
with moments like her husband who just
when she says something that doesn't
make sense to him he's just like
well okay then that you know she has a
way to
balance that and she's found people in
her life that find it at best
unobtrusive if not endearing and
i just really love the way she basically
scolds the doctor for not being with his
friends on christmas somebody should
have and she does it really well
number 18
dan lewis
now i did end up liking dan quite a bit
more than i thought i was going to when
it was first announced that john bishop
was going to be joining um the series
for flux i got actually really irritated
because i had hoped with ryan and graham
leaving that there was going to be a lot
more focus and attention paid to yasmin
and developing the um dynamic between
yasmin and the doctor and
bringing in another companion distracted
from that and it did but he is still an
endearing guy the reason he's not higher
than this is that pretty much everything
that i do
enjoy about him is a credit to john
bishop and a certain inherent endearing
nature to him as a performer because
there actually is very little to the
character i mean the things that we
learn about him that you know he wants
to do well by other people he it seems
to prioritize helping other people over
himself like he's helping with the food
pantry but he's not taking any for
himself despite the fact that he barely
has anything to his cabinet that does
tell us a little bit about him but
none of it really seems to come into
play
he's pretty underwritten
and he's largely saved by the charisma
of the performer which absolutely counts
for something that's why he's not lower
but you take him on paper and it's just
not much there
number 17
santa claus yeah nick frost got listened
to the credits i get to put sand on this
list and again a bit like madge is it
kind of silly cheesy
yeah but
nick frost is a real good santa and i
love that
wonderful jovial but like at the same
time not quite menacing but just
slightly i know more about what's going
on than you do vibe that he has when
interacting with someone like the doctor
especially but like right from the off
when he's talking to clara i just love
everything about what he brings forward
it feels very much like the realistic
version of what the legend would be so
it's not like undercutting the myths of
you know jolly caring and all of that
but it's like okay yeah but let's ground
him a little bit in terms of his
personality and everything but you can
also see from the way he interacts and
cares about people where the bigger myth
of the jolly um guy giving toys came
from
and
i like it
number 16
yasmin khan yes has actually kind of
benefited from me starting to do my
re-watch of the jody whitaker era so i'm
looking back at her from back in series
11 i'm realizing there is stronger and
more consistent groundwork played for
her as a person like her personality or
characterization then happened
definitely with ryan and arguably even
necessarily with graham now
she's not higher than this because i
feel like it
basically has a lot of missed
opportunities there's a lot more that
could have been done with her then
ultimately was and this isn't even about
the fact that i don't love the ship of
her and the doctor i don't but that's
not ultimately my disappointment with
her my disappointment was things like
well what i mentioned before dan coming
on board and missing the opportunity to
really dive into the connection she has
with the doctor and if you pay attention
to stuff that goes on in the background
it does get built over series 11 and 12
but it never really gets much of a
proper focus and if you're not paying
full attention then the moments where it
crops up more prominently it can feel
underdeveloped because they've been
doing it very quietly in the background
which in the hands of a stronger writing
team could have felt like good build up
but in the hands of the writing team
that chibnall headed it it didn't quite
pan out that way so i do like yaz well
as i said i actually like all these
people but
she can't go any higher than this
because there's so much unrealized
potential
to her as a character and as a companion
number 15
clara oswald i'm softer on clara than i
used to be i used to really dislike
clara the thing is
that first of all much like with dan
that is an issue of writing
not
of performance jenna coleman actually is
wonderfully charismatic as this
character i get why uh moffat kept her
around as much as i kind of wish he
hadn't he kept writing good exit points
for her and she kept not leaving but
the thing about clara is
her intro is weak
because uh c series 7 b where she gets
introduced properly the version of her
that we get that actually travels with
the doctor feels less developed and less
complete as a person than the one-off
versions we got in asylum of the daleks
and the snowmen so there's your first
issue but she also to my opinion doesn't
have a great rapport with smith it never
quite clicks i don't think that's
necessarily an issue of chemistry
between the performers so much as it is
that the entire reason the doctor is
even interested in her is because she's
mysterious to him and he's trying to
figure her out which
basically doesn't lend itself to
creating a good interpersonal dynamic
because
he's not traveling with her to get to
know her he's traveling with her to
unravel a mystery and it's just not a
terrific dynamic that having been said
she has much better chemistry with
capaldi the two characters click way way
better they actually
do a lot to bring out interesting
aspects of each other i don't
necessarily say the best aspects of each
other because part of the point that
hell bent was trying to make was that
what they brought out of each other
particularly what she brought out of him
was actually potentially dangerous
and there is that as well but that is
also interesting and layered and
watching that develop over time and i
actually i even like the relationship
that they had with her and danny pink
the way that played out and what it
showed about her as a person and her
priorities i feel like things just built
actually fairly well from the start of
series 8 with deep breath
right up through face the raven
then he'll bend happen and that's the
other reason why i can't put her higher
than this but
that middle stretch she does work
number 14
adelaide brook
back to a one-off appearance so this is
from waters of mars which is yes it's a
special that i've said and i do feel is
overrated in some circles drastically
overrated but is still good
and the performance of adelaide brooke
is absolutely one of the highlights she
has a wonderful
presence and you definitely get why this
is the person in charge she has that
vibe in that feeling as soon as she
shows up on camera and it's great to see
it first of all used to get her crew
in line and to try and get them off that
station and then later
trying to get the doctor to realize the
mistake he has made and is making
and having the strength of character to
go to the lengths that she does to snap
him out of it
so
it's just a really really powerful core
performance
it just is
number 13
jackson lake now i'm not gonna argue
that jackson lake is a better performed
or deeper and more nuanced character
than say adelaide brook
he just happens to click really well for
me especially
after he gets his own memories back like
him blustering about being the doctor
that's fun on its own but once he is
himself again
i love him
i love him so much to see
the fear
as a parent to see that fear when he
remembers and he sees his son in danger
to see the joy
at the doctor triumphing and especially
the interactions he has with the doctor
towards the very end when he sees the
tardis and he just has to step inside
and until it kind of overwhelms it he
describes it as wonderful nonsense and
then it overwhelms somebody he scoots
out like oh no no that's quite enough
i'm like you are
just a magical human being
i love that he
can understand the doctor enough
to see that the doctor is kind of
avoiding
some pain and like needs some
companionship but also
is enough of person of his time and his
own person that he's like i'm not
traveling with you it's too much for me
but i would still like you to join us
for christmas dinner
it's
there's just something about that when
that switch happens and he gets his own
personality back he just works for me on
just about every level
next up number 12
nardole nordle is uh well honestly a bit
like clara and even a bit like someone's
some of the characters i'm going to talk
about who are higher ranked than this
doesn't start out great his first
appearance in uh husbands of river song
is not very good he's actually kind of
irritating and the way he's played for
laughs grates on me real quick
he started to work better
with the next special the return of dr
mysterio but then by the time we got to
series 10
he actually works for me really well he
still has his little joke moments but
you get that determination from him that
he's there to keep the doctor in line
and that he takes that job
very seriously and that is a way to
inject
a spine into him as a character so that
yeah he's jokey yeah he's making silly
gags yeah he pulls goofy faces now and
then but
he also is not joking around when it
comes to the job he's there to do
and i like a character
who doesn't lose their personality in a
sense of who they are because they have
a job to do but when that job needs
doing yeah they will knuckle down and
they will do it i like naruto a lot for
that
number 11
graham o'brien
now as with some of the others a lot of
this is the performer bradley walsh
brings
a wonderful sense of
just wanting to explore more of the
universe but also
kind of getting that he doesn't get it
which is something that he's able to
bring to that part
i tend to like
the slightly older companions and not
just here like one of my favorite
companions from big finish is evelyn
smythe who part of why she's so good for
the sixth doctor is that she is at least
as far as physical appearance and her
general attitude a bit older than he is
and she stands up to him more as a
result now graham doesn't stand up to
the doctor more but he brings a
different dynamic having more life
experience than the others do and so for
him this is a bit more of a almost kind
of a bucket list thing to do rather than
a adventure of youth and that sense of i
can barely keep up but i don't want this
adventure to stop that he brings is
really endearing to me and also as much
as i
will continue to argue i don't think it
was necessary to kill off grace
he performs that grief and that loss
really
really well i mean the character suffers
from some of the writing inconsistencies
that
a lot of series 11 12 and flux suffer
from but
you probably notice them with him the
least because the performance elevates
all of it
to somebody who you're just like
i'm happy just to have you around and
just to even say little lines here and
there because he's always wanting to
help i think that's a big thing that's
like his core trait
he always wants to be helpful even if he
isn't sure the best way to do that
and not in like an insistent i must be
the one in charge way but just in a what
do you need tell me what you need i'll
do it
and it's that desire to help
that is actually written in as much as
i'm saying the performance elevates it
that is a written trait of the character
it is brought even more
by a perfect pairing of performer to
material
number ten
another one some people are going to get
mad at me for actually
rose tyler
i know some people are super into rose
seems like a lot of the people who are
are 10 and rose shippers which i'm
very much not
um but the thing with rose she actually
has one of the
more in-depth and nuanced relationships
with the doctor partly because of her
flaws as a person she is jealous she can
be petty sometimes in a way that makes
for a more interesting dynamic not only
with the doctor but with the other
people they encounter
but it's also a trait i don't really
care
for
it's not something i particularly enjoy
watching but that said billy piper
does have really good and unique
chemistry with both the ninth doctor and
the tenth doctor while i'm not a rose
intent shipper i get why people are and
it is interesting that it is a different
dynamic that she has with each version
of the doctor she travels with
but both are believable and believable
as coming from the same character i like
the way that she grounds the ninth
doctor and i like the way she energizes
the tenth doctor
she is really good for them and billy
piper does exude just that sense of
yeah i do kind of want to be around you
even though there's certain aspects of
your personality like i don't love but
for the most part yeah i do like again i
do like all these people but
yeah some people are gonna be mad at me
for putting her kind of middle like this
number nine
river song now there's another one that
might get controversial for some i know
people who don't like river song really
don't like river song and for a lot of
people she embodies the degradation of
moffat's writing to a certain extent and
admittedly she is unfortunately tied up
in some of his
most clunkily uh written or overwritten
uh or technobabble style stories things
like the wedding of riversong or let's
kill hitler which aren't great stories
but alex kingston
is always a highlight for me even in
those stories
her charm
and her ability to just
make me want to be around her and just
to see that smile that sense of swagger
that she brings whenever she shows up
yeah and kind of almost like an inverse
of clara
she starts really well because her
introduction in series 4 is immaculate
and while there's some wonkiness in the
middle
she also ends really well
husbands of river song when it's done
with its rollicking adventure story
which she's also good for just because
she has that swashbuckling kind of vibe
when it's done with that and it gets to
the emotional tail end and the coda
it's a really satisfying wrap up for
that character
so like i said it's like clara inverted
start strong end strong wobble in the
middle but
i just enjoy river's presence
despite unfortunately being tied to some
not great stories i still enjoy her
number eight
sarah jane smith
uh the late great elizabeth sladen
here's the thing
much like last time i did this i am only
taking her appearances in modern who
into account while she is a legacy
companion i am not counting
what she did in the classic era which
could either be to her benefit or
detriment because she wasn't written
super consistently at least in terms of
her function in the story sometimes she
was written great sometimes she was
written kind of disrespectfully for a
lack of a better way to put it
i like
the sense of experience that she brings
because she's
masterful
at being with someone like david tennant
and
seeing him and realizing as the doctor
and like it's like there's a flood of
everything
it just all comes into our face and you
can see the years
of experience that she's got and it all
comes forward in the performance and she
is
just
magnetic
you want her to stick around and i would
have liked her to appear more although i
know she had her own show going on um
which is a show i haven't talked about
and i don't really plan to the thing
about the sarah jane adventures is it
was
very much aimed at a younger gen
demographic than i am or even was at the
time it aired so it never quite clicked
with me but i do still appreciate it and
it is pretty good for what it is
and it is in a lot of ways carried by
her
the only thing that i don't love about
her is i don't like that they made her
kind of romantically pining for the
doctor i'm playing that very very
heavily which i don't love because that
really wasn't there during her time in
classic who but
even if i don't like that decision she
does play it well so
yeah
number seven
captain
jack harkness i am not going to be
addressing any of the controversies that
have gone on around john bearman i have
done multiple videos on them up to this
point so you can check out any number of
them if you want my thoughts on that
here i'm only talking about the
character and as with sarah jane smith i
am only dealing with the character here
in modern era doctor who i am not taking
torchwood into account which here is
definitely to his benefit because here
he is swashbuckling and he is fun
torchwood seemed to forget that he was
supposed to be fun
a lot of the time and sometimes it
worked like it worked on children of
earth because that story that story's
not fun and it's not supposed to be but
as a character he just was not nearly as
fun in torchwood here whenever he shows
up
he's fun
he does work best i feel with the ninth
doctor because he brings
a sense that the ninth doctor himself
doesn't have that sort of swashbuckling
adventure sense because the doctor at
that point is very much
kind of in um
well trauma recovery from everything
that went on in the time war
and whereas when jack is paired with 10.
while they still work it's a little bit
different because 10 kind of has that
swashbuckling thing on his own so you
don't need jack there but jack is still
fun
whatever you think or feel about john
barrowman at this point my own feelings
are on the complicated side
there's still just such a high degree of
joy that i still experience
every time he shows up on screen and
that is that is worth quite a bit to me
number six
rory williams
rory
is a character who i like more every
time i revisit him every time i go back
and i watch him get more sure of himself
be willing to stand up to the doctor get
more confident in who he is and how he
fits into this overall dynamic within
the tardis every time i watch him go
through that i like him more
he is admittedly
a bit more of a companion to amy than he
is to the doctor like i don't think he
ever would have traveled with the doctor
if he wasn't there but
so what
his
devotion and his caring and sometimes
being or at least trying to be the voice
of reason when the doctor and amy are
just more interested in adventure he
brings a really good additional dynamic
so that
the three of them never felt overcrowded
i tend to be an advocate for single
companion when it comes to the doctor
rather than having two or definitely
three companions at once
but that having been said the three of
them because of how they played off each
other and because rory was there more
for amy than the doctor it just made for
a really good group dynamic but even on
his own
he's just a really endearing sweet guy
and he makes so much sense once you meet
his dad
number five
martha jones a doctor martha jones at
this point
martha's another character who i have
come to appreciate more and more as time
has gone on
i think i kind of underappreciated her
for a few reasons first initially she
only had the one series so i didn't feel
like i got to know her as well but then
in addition to that in some ways series
3 doesn't actually do her proper justice
it tries in its own way
but i'm not sure it actually does the
character great and i definitely don't
love that she pines for the doctor
romantically
but that having been said
the fact that she
takes that
as a character and uses it as a reason
to be her own person and to leave
because it's what's better for her and
she needs to put herself over him
that counts for a lot and even before
that martha is
uh is inquisitive she's smart
just and honestly her introduction in
smith jones is gold i think that's a
really underappreciated episode it's fun
and of itself but as a as a companion
intro it's dang you're perfect
she's
a really strong person
and the show at its best does a real
good job of showing that even when she
has to kind of her own say
have to clamp it down a little bit
with things like human nature
and i think it's the fact that it felt
like she got backgrounded a little bit
in stuff like that or in blink where i
had to really
go through like second or third rewatch
to really be like
i haven't been giving you the credit you
deserve
and she keeps climbing up the list every
time i do it
number four
amy pond amy pawn to me
is basically
rose
minus the aspects of rose that rubbed me
the wrong way a little bit
she doesn't have that same kind of
jealousy towards uh you know the doctor
showing interest in literally anything
that isn't her the way that rose did
and that kind of makes a big difference
but she has a very similar kind of
sassy relationship with the doctor and i
love their dynamic again
excellently introduced in her first
appearance because since he's her
childhood friend imaginary friend as far
as anyone was concerned she both
adores him
but is also kind of already fed up with
his nonsense because he left her alone
for years
so
the
push and pull of that that she can be in
awe of him yet also able to call him out
on his bs when she has to
that balance works really well
especially with a doctor whose motto at
times was the doctor lies well she's
someone who's not gonna let him get away
with that she was really good for that
doctor for smith's doctor in specific
and she manages to have that strength
without being perfect
she can have flawed moments she can make
questionable decisions i don't love that
she tries to jump the doctor's bones but
you know again me and the romantic
angle stuff i just never really works
for me so not a perfect run but
i enjoy her presence so much and i like
what she brings out of smith and again
the three-way dynamic with amy rory and
the doctor is one of my favorite tardis
teams
number three
bill potts
bill's another one who i appreciate more
every time i watch her again
she is
inquisitive kind of in the way that
martha was but she doesn't have the same
level of education so her questions are
often a lot more kind of blunt she's
frequently asking the questions that
well
you or i might ask
people who are going wait a minute wait
what
you know questioning basic premises at
times but in a way that for me at least
was never annoying
and she was again the perfect companion
for where capaldi was at that time
for him to take someone who wanted to
experience more and to learn and that he
the appeal of her to him
was that in a class where everyone else
would get confused and frown and she'd
get confused and smile
she knows the universe is too big for
her ever to understand
and that excites her
that doesn't frustrate her
and that's
frankly a perspective that i share
so
that helps a bit but the way that she is
able to interact with the doctor and
challenge him at times
is really well done
and she also has a very fully developed
sense of her own life which doctor has
tried to do a few times i think most
notably with clara
which sometimes worked sometimes didn't
with bill it actually works quite well
for me because we get just enough taste
of it of her
trying to go on dates of her working at
the school but it also never feels
intrusive to her adventures with the
doctor it just feels like
giving her a sense of her entire life
does not revolve around traveling with
this guy
and given the show's tendency to
have a companion get so
involved with the doctor that it does
seem like that's kind of their entire
life at this point which is part of why
the companion exits are almost always
tragic including bills
unfortunately but it doesn't feel like
her entire life gets subsumed by the
doctor
and that to me makes her a stronger
character
i really love bill
number two
wilfred mott
i said i was a sucker for the older
companions
wilf
is one of the best
the sense of
experience
that he brings not only to his
interactions with the doctor which like
that conversation between him and the
10th doctor
on that ship orbiting earth is
amazing wonderful and it breaks my heart
and
things like that but also
seeing him
in something like left turn
and
from experience he knows how bad things
are in a way that donna doesn't get
immediately
it's
easy to have old people in a show like
this and have that be the butt of jokes
oh they can't run around as fast they
can't keep up with trying to understand
the technology but the benefit if you do
it right is you can allow their wealth
of experience to inform
how they react and how they respond to
what's going on and wilf
does that in spades
you get that sense of a very fully lived
life for better and worse behind
everything he says
feels does the joy
that he is able to bring
as well as the melancholy and sadness at
times
it's not easy
to take a character who by any measure
of society has passed their prime and
probably past most of their use
and have the doctor sacrifice himself to
save that person
and never doubt that question for a
second
that is absolutely the right decision
the doctor has a little hissy fit willf
says he shouldn't do it but yeah he
should
because wilf is precious
wolf is a treasure
and
i love him
which brings us to number one
which has not changed from the last time
i did this because number one still
donna noble
she is
for me
the platonic ideal
of the companion
and i do mean platonic ideal very
literally there is zero romantic angle
between her and the doctor she's kind of
grossed out by the suggestion and both
of them are always constantly going oh
no we are not together and that's not
like a build up to oh they'll fall in
love no they don't that's not what
they're here for
she's here to be his friend
she's here to remind him when he's
overstepping to ground him
he's here to show her a breadth of
experience that she can't get anywhere
else
they're there to call each other out for
nonsense they're there to make each
other better
remember how i kind of mentioned that
clara and the 12th doctor kind of made
each other worse but in a way that was
like most of the time decently written
here what i love about don is she
and the 10th doctor make each other
better
at every step
and donna was a character who i did not
like in her first appearance and even
going back and re-watching the runaway
bride knowing donna is going to be my
favorite companion i still don't like
her in that
but it is also kind of necessary
for those experiences to change her as
much as they do
she is
vibrant
she takes no crap not from the doctor
not from aliens not from anybody
she
is the perfect balance to me
of someone who
yes wants to travel with the doctor
forever but not because she's infatuated
with him not because he's swallowed her
entire life
but because
this is the fun and the joy
and the sense of discovery and amazement
that she doesn't want to let go
donna noble
best companion of the modern era
what do you think how would you rank
these how badly do you think i screwed
this up like i said this is actually
tough to talk about because i don't flat
out just like any of them but i still
have to give justifications for why some
are higher and some are lower and
maybe i explained it in a way that makes
sense maybe i didn't but whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it patreon is
not only what pays the bills but also
was what determined this to be the video
this month i gave a number of options
for uh revisiting a ranking of doctor
who related stuff and the patrons voted
this was the one they wanted it was by a
very narrow margin might have only been
one vote but if you want to participate
in polls like that see videos early most
of the time when i'm properly on
schedule
any tier of support you get those perks
and plus there's others at other tiers
of support but don't worry too much
about that like share subscribe also
help me out those don't cost you
anything but
what i really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
now my thanks to my highest supporting
patrons robin moore zubin lutfullah
barack the thing that goes doink in the
anime oliver b melinda walters udelke
the oath of boyd bernabeu lacks the
poodle zach idolin tracy skravitt angry
casper bookworm adam rdl taylor shane
ross
gourley brendon the rose and tt you want
to hear me possibly butcher your name
check out the rewards on the patreon
and thanks to all you folks
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]